chellamma column I was taking English
because we record this for all the
people who can make it and my name is
Shira and Zito said and I'm a data
scientist at Dubai and first of all I
want to say in a personal note that I'm
very happy to be here today it was my
personal goal to create a community of
professionals that I can talk to it and
consult with and it's really happening
here so thank you all guys for making it
happen and and that's it let's start so
my talk would be composed of two parts
the first part would be a story of a
model I worked on and my job and about a
little about continuous model training
and the second part would be about a
model explanation framework called lime
which help us interpret our models in a
deeper way than we usually do so let's
start with the first part and I was
asked to build a model for returning
clients and returning debtors a blue
line and now you probably don't
understand what it means so for you to
understand better you need to know what
is blue line so I prepared a short movie
to explain that
maybe you're the CEO of a marketing
agency or your engineering diesel you
might even tame elephants for a living
but no matter what you do it often seems
like what you end up doing most is
waiting yes waiting teacher invoices
faked waiting and waiting and waiting
these cashflow gaps make it hard to
manage expenses also if you can't get
the money here now you can reinvest it
in Berlin your business now you can
introduce you but a fast and easy way to
get an advance on your invoices signing
up with blue line is easy enter a few
details about yourself and your business
and connect your invoicing or accounting
software now your unpaid invoices will
automatically appear in your dashboard
select from one or more invoices to
advance with a click of a button you can
get cash as little as 24 hours for your
first invoice advance and even sooner
for repeat usage so how does your
customer pay blue hi when the invoice is
due and once you're approved on new line
you'll receive a blue fund account a
unique bank account number and a
physical p.o box address both in your
business name with the bank account
number you will be able to accept
electronic payments and with your
the box checks and since your online
account is in your name your customers
can continue making the payments in your
name sign up with blue Viper stop
waiting and free up your cash today
Luva and fast funding simple and
transparent 100% online okay so now you
understand what Lubin does we actually
help small businesses get an advance on
their invoices and now to connect you to
the model I had to work with that to
explain you the terms what is the client
and what is the debtor and what is a
returning fire and death or so for
example say that you are an exterminator
you exterminate bugs and a law firm
asked you to come and make a job for
them and you come there and you do a job
but you don't get paid immediately you
get paid in the end of the month or in
60 days according to the terms of your
deal and so when you want the money now
because you need to pay your workers or
you need to invest in marketing then you
come to us to bluevine and you give us
give us your invoice we give you an
advance on your invoice and in the end
of the month when a payment is due the
debtor just the the law firm just pays
us directly the money so this is what
it's called factoring and this is a very
large business in the United State
they're very many many companies that
does that but what's so special in blue
line is that it's 100% online and also
that we are all machine learning model
based decisions so everything happens
really fast a client can get money to
his account in just a few hours and so
one of these very smart models I had to
work on is a model for returning clients
and returning debtors meaning clients
that we already had deals with for
example if this exterminator has already
done a deal before and got funding from
blue line and he done did any Duty still
with the same law firm before then this
is a deal that I would train on in my
model okay so when this is the model I
had to build and and first of all I have
to generate the data so I have of course
features of the deal itself the amount
of money and the duration of the deal
but I also have features of the client
because this is a client we already
worked with
so we know about the history of his
payments and what is he standing in the
banks in addition I have information
about the data because we already work
with this debt or as well my my model
goals is to actually predict whether
this will be a good deal because what we
want to do we want to approve this deal
automatically without an analyst touch
without no one seeing it and so what
does it mean that the deal is good it
means that we proved it and that it was
paid on time on terms and this is an
example of a data frame and from my data
that I use just an example of three
features of my whole data set they have
many features one of the feature is
client negative web appearances this is
for example one of the features we
collect on our clients and as you can
see say it's a binary feature binary
features true or false and we have a
feature of debt or average in versus
amount is a numerical feature and
feature of the deal the duration of the
deal and it's good is the level as I
said whether the deal is good and all is
paid on terms so what can we see here
that there is a mixture of different
types of features there are a binary
feature there are numerical feature
maybe there are also categorical
features so this is not trivial in
machine learning because many machine
learning models make assumptions on the
on their features that they are maybe
normally distributed or Bernoulli
distributed if you want to use machine
learning models when they are from
mixture of different types you need to
do something maybe you should change
your data to all of the data being
binary or maybe you need to change your
model to treat differently there a
binary variables and treat differently
the numerical variables or you can do
something else and it just use a tree
based model and why use a tree based
model because it doesn't make any
assumption on the underlying
distribution of the data and
it's very it's very good for these kind
of problems and but I don't just use a
decision tree a classical decision tree
I use for example random forests and why
do we like random forest so much random
forest is a combination of many decision
trees and do you hear me in the back
it's okay yeah okay so and so as I said
random forest is a combination of many
decision trees meaning that first of all
they can work with a with a mixture of
different type of features as I said but
they also better than single decision
trees because they are an average of
many decision trees built on different
subsets on the death of the data and
different subsets of the feature by
creating this different decision trees
which are different from another and
averaging the results we create low
variance model which means it has also a
lower error so it makes it much more
robust in addition one very good entry
base model they mean random forest is
that it has a way to capture the
relation between features very well for
example if I would use a linear model
then if I would want to capture the
relation between two features I will
have to add another feature for example
with the ratio of two feature or with
other a kind of function between the two
features but when I use trees which is
actually in the end just a bunch of
rules combined together then it gives
space to a very complex functions rigged
with different features from the data so
and I took a random forest and I am just
another thing and I need to address to
here and that I have an unbalanced data
set like in most project action problems
I only have about three 3% bad deals and
just to clarify what are bad deals for
us badias are deals that were rejected
by our analysts or something like that
or deals that were approved but in the
end was not paid on terms okay so I also
have to address this problem in the data
and how people usually
handle unbalanced issues is by a over
sampling their minority cross or under
settling in the majority class so then I
decided to just go on and try a model on
my data the model I was trying to build
was already a is already an existing
version this is actually the second
version of this model and I said well
the data should be pretty good let's
just go and see what happens when I
throw everything to random forest and do
10-fold cross-validation let's see what
are the results and then I got this Wow
looks amazing right for those of you of
you who are not familiar with this kind
of plot this is the ROC curve and what
we see here is the true positive rate
versus the false positive rate and the
blue line is the new perfect model the
Green Line is the old model which is
okay and what you can see for example in
this point I mark there there is a very
very high troop a true positive right
around 95% and very very low false
positive rate close to zero
so it's perfect result I can go home go
to the beach have fun that's it but then
I looked again I said well data doesn't
act like this usually just like that you
get perfect results and so I decided to
dig in and do some experiments and
understand where where is the problem
so when first of all I looked at model
feature importance and future importance
is the estimation of the reduction of
accuracy of the model if you remove a
feature from the model and the first one
is like the most important feature of
the model and this is by the order and I
looked for anything I have something
weird that we look weird in the eyes an
idea tark at something that's licking
the target and
and what I saw was pretty normal I mean
I looked at the features I'm like okay
client payment history to climate
history family story it's all kind of
variations on there on the knowledge we
have about the payment history of the
client which is pretty logical I mean we
already have information about the
current orchid already worked with it
it's the best prediction to how it's
going to behave now right so nothing
seemed weird to me and also the deal
amount is very logical that it will be
in the future importance so I decided to
try something else and make some
experiments I took only the 10 best
features and did again cross validation
on my model only with the 10 best
features and look I still got really
amazing results and I didn't know what
to do
why how to to ruin this model and so I
tried something else I took that and
worst features and this is what I got
it's still really good results so when I
then I just said okay maybe we'll just
go crazy and just take two features and
still I got pretty good results for two
features only to the two best features
but still only two features that was
something here is weird but if we use
only two features it's supposed to be a
pretty simple model maybe I can just
look at one of the trees from the random
forest and understand what is the
problem
so I plotted one of the trees just a
random tree for my model this is what I
got really really huge tree
you can't understand much because it's
just really really huge but what you can
understand is that this tree has many
many leaves and all of this just based
on two features so it's like I don't
know a candle or something and like the
lamp under my head but the model is
memorizing something is learning
specific values of something but what I
mean I do cross-validation right I I
take some deers train the model on them
I take other deals and test them all on
them what why what is it memorizing so
mmm do you have any idea what could have
happened here
okay that's a very good point but no it
can't happen because I didn't talk about
it but my daughter generation it's not
that simple I don't just take all the
client features at the moment I take all
the client feature as they were at the
time of the deal creation only the
history of the client which was true at
the time of the declarations so I don't
actually leak information about the
specific deal for it for when I generate
the data yes that's a very good point
and I actually try that but I still got
really bad results and I would explain
later why but it's a really good idea
okay now I will continue because we
don't have much time sorry okay so I
tried to do something else and instead
of just randomly a doing
cross-validation I decided to divide my
data in a different way in a way that
will simulate the future better and how
did they do that we didn't talk about it
but many of our clients are returning
clients they clients make many deals
with bluevine and also my data set it
includes many deals from the same client
and I didn't think about it but maybe
there's something important here so I
decided instead of doing cross
validation just randomly I did something
else I trained the model on certain
deals from certain clients and I tested
the burner the model on deals from other
clients the clients that the model have
not seen on train and this was the
result I got
fiddling and then I said oh no bring
back my beautiful rock was so nice I so
wanted to once have such a great model
but no and so this really led me to that
to understand that here is the problem
here is my problem and what is exactly
the problem
so probably they classified instead of
learning a deal it is memorizing their
clients and what does it mean why does
it memorize the clients so we have to
ask three questions to understand this
better first of all how many deals per
client do we have in our data how many
how many times a client will repeat in
my data second floor is clamped behavior
consistent to usually client with
goodies have only good ears or client
with baddies only have bad deals and
third how similar are deals from the
same client can the mother really
recognize a certain deal is from a
certain client and so when let's check
all of these three points so this is the
deal per client count
it's a histogram of the number of deals
per client and what we can see here that
well yeah
most of the client in our data has
multiple deals around 90% and some of
them even have dozen and hundreds of
deals in my data so it will maybe make a
model it will make it a model easier to
learn the specific clients so yes on the
first one and and then they I wanted to
check it declined behave a really
consistent so I want to look and I
thought that we always approve their
client we always a perverse a 75% client
with good deals and we always reject 10%
of the client
only 45414 percent of the clients the
the behavior is not consistent meaning
that yes
if the model can learn to recognize a
specific client which is good it will
improve all these deals and get perfect
results on them and they say for a bad
client and then I want to check how
similar are deals from the same client
and I got this random plot of similarity
between deals and in dark purple with
the high similarity and light purple
it's low similarity and the diagonal is
all a dark purple because deals are
similar to themselves but we see here
another a dark purple and this is
because deal five is from client 15 and
the one is on also from client 15 that's
why they are very similar so this also
backs my assumption that this from the
same client are similar but left feet on
the whole data set this is just a small
example so what I did to check on the
whole data set if these from the same
client are actually similar I calculated
for each dealer what is the most similar
deal in the data and then I took all of
these values of similarity similarities
from zero to one and they took all these
values of maximum similarity and plotted
and put this on a histogram and as you
can see here there is a high peak around
one meaning that most of the deals has
at least one very similar deal in my
data set so it backed my something that
if I have many deals from the same
client they are very similar another
thing I checked is how many features of
my features our client features because
I said deal features and data features
in client features and as you can see
here 71% of my features are client
features which is a lot so it's logical
it would be easy to learn the specific
clients so the conclusion from all of
these check that is actually this model
just
memorize the clients instead of learning
the pattern of a good deal
so anyways how can we solve this issue
what why do you mean you buy that
[Music]
but I don't understand only I have in
each of your boats open thing will be
built from different clients okay but I
do that I divided the trail and the
tests are from different clients already
that's what I did
mine okay folks okay okay maybe you have
my goddamn list on you but you can tell
me later
any other ideas okay a good idea hahaha
good idea okay so when I got it right
and what I did and is actually just take
my data set and shrink it a lot just
sample one deal per client and then if I
take the measure I showed you before of
similarity between deals from this blue
pick we see here we receive this red
thing which is much more flatter it
means that this has much less similar
deals in the data set so I got a data
set which is less correlated the samples
are less correlated its D correlated but
I still have a problem now that I have a
much smaller sample size so how can I
deal with that so what I did in the end
and my final solution is using an
example instead of just taking one deal
Pro Klein and training immoral and that
it that would be my model I did it a few
times and the final model is an example
model based on the average of the
decision of all of these models trained
on different deals per client but only
one deal Pro client
and here are some results what we can
see from left to right this is the
result for only one classifier for a
random forest the blue for the new model
and the green for the old one and I
added more and more classifiers and we
can see some mild improvement here in
the ROC curve but it's not amazing yes
and and then to make my model stronger I
decided to try something else something
new I heard about lately and which is
called active boost you probably heard
about it as well it's a cackler champion
winner it won most of their of the
competition of kegels this weird has a
some part in the winning solution and as
you can see it got me really great
results and so I was very happy and and
it's also based on trees it's just based
on boosting which sequentially build
trees which learns from the from the
previous trees mistakes so it's a more
robust than random forest and and then
they I got this nice results of the
point two zero 77 rock which is it ok
let's go into production this is enough
for us and but then I had just one more
problem the problem is that how models
usually work is that they are trained
offline and the prediction is done
online and this is great if we assume
that the world is not changing with the
world is stationary and but in fact the
world is not like that people are
changing and our policies for
improvement of deal change all the time
and we have to deal with that somehow so
what we did is be the front framework to
continuously train the models online and
without our intervention and how it
works is that the model is trained every
week on the most up-to-date data it just
reads the data from the database trains
the model and we deploy the new model
only if it's comparable or better or
better than
old model and in this way we prevent the
model from degrading and also prevent it
from getting irrelevant so that's it for
the first part if you have any questions
it's a very good point
waiting in sales about month
it's a good idea I might try that in the
next revision but I I I'm not sure it
will make better results because one but
maybe yeah maybe if yeah okay
I'm sorry I didn't quite get it but
maybe you want to come here so I'll hear
you better classify the clients and
other transaction because I did I have
different amount of data on each client
and I want to be able to give an answer
about a certain deal and use also the
deal features so it's a different
problem we also have models that work
only about clients and about approve
improvement of clients but this is a
model specific for deals and for
returning clients so I hope that answer
it but if you want you can we can talk
about it later okay so let's move on to
the second part because we still have
more things we want to talk about and so
in the first part we saw a model that
worked perfectly on validation data but
in fact was not good at all it was just
memorizing the clients instead of
learning what is a good deal and and
this is their one of my motivations to
look at something like this you a model
explanation usually a machine learning
models are very complex and we can't
really understand how they work we just
treat them at the black box we train
them and then we test them on other data
and see their performance that's how we
evaluate if they're working we just test
them on validation but we don't actually
look inside them and see how they work
so this is a really cool framework
developed by guys from Washington
University
it's called lime and it's a framework
that can explain any machine learning
model if explain specific predictions of
the model it actually gives reasons why
does this sample it was predicted to be
good or bad or whatever is the label so
I will show a few examples
first of all a picture of dogs oh it
would be something nice also in the
presentation and this is the my example
data leakage the the line guys what they
did and they took the Google a inception
Network and they gave it photos of
wolves and for the loved Eskimo Dogs
husky dogs this cute things here and
they wanted to train the network to
distinguish between these two types of
dogs and so but they also want to
confuse the network so what they did
they took only photos of wolves with
snow in the background and photos of
husky dogs with some background but not
snow ok
and when the network performed perfectly
on the validation that of this sort it's
recognized all the works and as well as
and all the husky dogs with husky dogs
but then they give the network this
photo or the husky with snow in the
background and of course what the
network said said that this is a wolf
because it has snow in the background
and what lime produces is the pixels
that's mostly contributed to this
prediction and in this case you can see
the explanation is the snow in the
background so the network instead of
learning to recognize the differences of
the interfaces of the wolves and dogs
just don't recognize that if it's not
then it's a wolf and so it's a nice nice
way to show what is data leakage data
leakage is in fact when you have
features in the data which reveal the
target and these features would not be
actually present as is in the real world
so it makes your model actually really
bad because it learns the the data
leakage instead of learning the right
patterns you want to know so it's kind
of similar to what I had but but
different
so another nice day this was an example
of how lime can show you when a model is
bad is learning the wrong thing and now
this is an example of how lime can show
your model is also good and this is a
photo of a Labrador playing guitar and
the Google inception Network also it
gave three predictions they try to
recognize what is in this photo it gave
three prediction the first strongest one
was electric guitar which is not
entirely true because this is an
acoustic guitar but the explanation you
see here of an electric guitar is
actually the part that looks like an
electric guitar so it makes sense it
said also acoustic guitar and it's very
reasonable because chose the parts of
the guitar that looks like a Christian
guitar and it also said a Labrador and
the Pixlr which explains it is the lover
of faith so and we see that the
prediction is not perfect but the
reasons are very logical so we can trust
it network that it does logical
assumptions so what is lime and lime is
generated actually just by taking the
very complex model and trying to
estimate it locally around the sample we
want to explain and here for example you
have this specific cross this is for
example a example one explained the
classification border between the two
classes is very complex as you can see
and what lime does actually is to
estimate this line and if we know design
we can understand this model better
because linear model is much more
interval than this complex model and how
does it do that
it creates a examples which are similar
to this example just by adding random
noise to this example and it correct
rejection predictions for this
additional examples and then I create a
linear estimation from from
to the model around that sample and then
what we in fact look at in the
explanation are the specific features
which were the strongest in this linear
line and just the last thing I want to
show you to close the loop to make us a
closure is that I applied line and took
it and applied it on my initial model
and on my final model and as you can see
here I took care I took a specific
example of a client which is a bad deal
and what you see and this is the text
the time can produce it says the
features and the values of the features
and here it's the contribution it is a
plus if it's for the good side and of
the deal is if you say it's a good deal
and - if it's a it's a bad deal and here
also in columns the good and the bad
features and lists of the features and
you can see also the code here I can
send you the code later if you want you
can also find it at Google and you can
see that this is the initial model and
all the features here by lying say that
this models are this deal is bad which
is a bit weird because all of the
features here are first of all client
specific features and all of them are
numerical and if you look at the ranges
that are very specific for example
client history one this is some feature
which talked about the history of the
client not necessarily better good if it
is between 1400 and 2100 it says it is
very bad this implies that it learned
specific values of this feature and say
it's bad so it actually learns the
client so we can just see what we saw in
the first part but through line here
that this a model just learned the
client instead of learning the pattern
of good deals
and if we look at the final model we see
that the prediction is also correct as
it was in the first first model in
addition model but the reasons here are
right because if we look at the good
column and the bad column and the good
column we have for example client bailed
history is zero which is good because
the the bad history for this client is
zero it's something good so it's logical
that it would be in the good column and
clad clients bad history is far this is
larger than their zero then it's it's
logical that this would be something bad
and so here it's much more balanced
pictures not everything is bad and it
makes sense so and this is how we can
use line and that's it
that was my talk and we talked about a
model with perfect validation results
which was in fact useless because it
just memorized the client and we talked
about how I am I found a solution for
this problem I'm sampling a few models
trained on one deal per client data sets
and we talked about how to deal with a
non-stationary world by a keep on a
training our model online on production
and andean we showed an explanation
framework that enables us to understand
any machine learning model and open up
their black boxes and that's it
questions
[Applause]
so thank you and we are hiring and this
is my email you can also send me
questions or send your CV for interested
and that's it yes it just works
it's really amazing really really easy
you just give it the model you give you
the features names and it just works
yeah really great yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
while you could do like somebody's
mentioned before just use just separate
the clients and then you can use the
transactions so now the number of
transaction per client if you can take
the simplest way is number one of
classifiers we have any one sample yes
but if I will use all them once then the
model with the client
yeah the validation results would not be
good but the model would not learn the
right thing I went to the model to learn
and the minute I supplied the model many
views from the same client it recognized
ah this client is a good because of this
deal is good and so instead of learning
the pattern of Goodyear's it learns what
is this client how to recognize this
specific client
it's not exactly the same there might be
some changes because time changes of
course maybe deals are from different
times but they are similar that's what
we see in fact yeah yes you mentioned
that you automatically retraining the
model and then compare it and change it
in production so what is the method that
you use exactly to compare and to see
the model is worse switching to the next
one it's a very good question I actually
use all three metrics that I have I use
rock and I use precision and I was
recall because and we do have some
threshold to when we approve deals and I
want to keep some precision and recall
for this threshold yeah the validation
what I do and I didn't talk about it too
much but I told you that I switched on
the validation instead of doing cross
validation I do validation only on deals
from clients that the more of not seen
so that's what I do along the whole way
I do ten for validation but in this way
like want a corollary sample okay yes
that's actually a good point
and I haven't think about yet but let's
say just it's not that easy to trick our
models I mean it's based on many many
features together and you need to forge
a lot of things together to specifically
understand what the model is proving but
that's an idea what we will see it over
time I mean this pretty new so some
companies in this space letting some web
users get through I have divided that
the doors are the bare nails and then
use it for
okay and so I think we're out of time
right yeah okay so we're okay okay so
we'll just take five minutes break and
then we'll continue with the next
lecture thank you
[Applause]